my wife bought five horses using credit
cards without my knowledge whoa she's
sold three of the horses but now one of
the two remaining horses is sick she
bought the horse for five thousand
dollars and hopes to sell it for two
thousand dollars if it's healthy I would
like to euthanize the horse but my wife
doesn't have a problem going into more
debt to save it how do we Define a limit
on expenses for the horse's recovery
after which if he doesn't get well we
can just decide for euthanasia oh my are
you sweating I have assorted past with
horse related questions obviously I am
not a part of the equestrian Community I
think there's another option you sink
another five grand into the horse to get
it back on its Hooves my option would be
why don't we try to market the horse
privately or look into horse rescues
that would be willing to take this horse
on and help it recover